you had someone do this incredible  depiction that's you standing in front  of it yes well no that's the artist  slush sucks he's an Australian street  art I see who had a nude image of me and  he painted it on a wall outside  somewhere in Australia and it got  covered up very quickly and the police  were called but I actually you texted me  a nude a long time ago we were texting  back and forth and you you're constantly  texting me nudes like I fell over and  over and over again and I don't recall  but not to an inappropriate level like  I'm gonna call the cops kind of level  but anyway I forwarded a nude to the  street artists and he actually painted a  Conan nude mural out in Australia this  is up right now I brought the image with  me  [Applause]  that is not Photoshop that is a hundred  percent real it's exactly what my ass  looks like - fantastic  I want to go I'm going to Australia I  want to see that  you